what's up it's the chickenhawk mac1o
catch me on the bootleg cab podcast 100.
bolay calf show special guest
Legend ladies and gentlemen Mac 104 show
Mac 10 is in the building man what's up
with it homie how you doing I'm such a
big fan of yours that I own thicker than
water on VHS oh
um
yeah I've seen a couple of them in the
garage on VHS yeah yeah I always tell
people I'm like y'all don't understand
like when you had like who banging
records like CMAC and you were dropping
movies and like I feel like you were
kind of doing this like real independent
West Coast for everybody like kind of
like you know obviously you were doing
your thing on the major level but you
also had like who banging records was
going I remember every damn Source
magazine at double XL y'all had the full
ads and everything man
that's how you had to do it then you
know what I'm saying so you know when
when I play I'm gonna play yeah so you
know I wouldn't uh you know cutting no
corners or nothing we was trying to get
to it yes sir what have you been up to
lately man I feel like you've obviously
kind of taken a step back you got the
new single out but you've kind of been
you know I feel like you've been kind of
away from music for a while
I have a
the artist side of it you know what I'm
saying but I've been really involved
with um you know as being like a concert
promoter you know what I'm saying I've
heard that too yeah since like 2010 or
11 like I've been like my bread and
butter like I'll do a couple of hundred
shows a year wow that I promote so you
know I I've been in the music business
but I just it's not been making music
yeah you know what I'm saying I've been
putting shows on man you know what like
uh because obviously from an artist's
perspective you see you'd be like damn
okay I got paid this much but the show
sold out so the promoter made this much
so what made you kind of get into the
promoter game
I don't have nights where I had four or
five shows going in one night in
different states
just as a promoter just as much I might
have had
key sweating
uh
Kansas City or something right you know
somebody else in somewhere and somebody
else somewhere and somewhere and I might
have been
doing Crush groove or something right
I'm saying he just I didn't in immense
situations like that where I really had
like four or five shows going in one
night damn dude yeah the promoter game
is is it do you feel like because I do
feel like
there's kind of
probably a saturated Market in people
trying to throw shows do you feel like
you found like a niche in the type of
artisan type of [__] you're doing well
the thing is is that
anybody could try to do it but you got
to get good at it in order for it to be
you know and you got to be willing you
you you got to have enough to lose yep
it's like going to Vegas like if you
stand at the crap table you shouldn't be
standing there with nothing that you you
care if you lose it straight up you feel
me so so like that's the same thing with
this you know it's a gamble but but like
you know as you as you get good at it
you learn like what's a smart bet and
what's not a smart bet you know what I'm
saying but you got to be able to like uh
you know withstand losing you you you
got to be able to deal with that because
that's a part of the game so are you
this tour that you just announced uh
it's you I saw a man of Perez design a
lot of people think dog pounds on the
tour dog pound Warren G quick yeah
sugar-free are you that's your tour are
you like you're the promoter as well
yeah doubling up why not why not man why
not yo I just gotta say dude like uh
you're like there's not a lot of people
I'll call a legend but I do feel like
you are
one of the greatest to ever come out of
the West Coast
um well I appreciate that
Banger ball is low-key your most slept
on album
I was a high record yo that dude that do
the damn thing dude yeah man that I just
feel like you have so much catalog like
today I was like riding around like God
damn I forgot about hating your eyes and
this is so much [__] yeah
um for you do you feel like because
you're kind of like behind the scenes
now you're not as visible as maybe some
of your peers when we think of West
Coast Legends these days do you feel
like you get the the love and respect
you you deserve and when we talk about
that
yeah but most of all I feel like I get
the money that's all that matters you
feel that's the kind of guy yeah yeah
they could have all that other [__] give
me the bag I respect that I don't give a
[__] about famous or none of that you
care about the bag that's some real [__]
you know that's some real [__] yeah so
so like if I cared about famous
it wouldn't have took me 14 years to do
another record right it's been that long
yeah 2009. that was the last time you
put out music yeah I put an album yeah
Jesus so if I cared about famous you and
with this internet [__] and everything
how it is you know I would have been in
front of the camera yeah but I've been
getting to the back so you know that's
that's you know I feel good about that
you were the first guy I ever heard talk
about Englewood on records and now
obviously Inglewood has blown up a lot
of people are saying it's become
gentrified so if my Stadium's over there
um
uh how do you feel about Inglewood these
days man because it is kind of the it
City now in L.A I've been to his City
for me my whole life of course you know
but that's for like everybody the
Clippers are gonna play there I mean you
know we we welcome everybody with open
arms it's all good you know I love
Englewood man yeah you know that's
that's that's always home at the end of
the day there's a dope uh obviously a
lot of dope artists coming out of
Inglewood are you hip to like guys like
Ruchi and like that kind of oh yeah oh
yeah and I love to see little Ruchi and
them getting theirs you know what I'm
saying like like I'm I'm a real like
fan of the youngsters you know because
everybody had a Time yep and you know
I've been blessed man God has been good
to me in this game so like
I ain't the kind of God to like not want
everybody to win you know what I'm
saying you're a sucker if you don't want
everybody to win that's hater type [__]
it's real [__] man you feel me so so
like it's enough money for everybody
they print it every day 100 man that's
some real [__] uh yo I think back to
like some of your catalog you've been a
part of so many dope projects obviously
uh
man the recipe I mean I'm at the West
Coast the West Side connection [__] like
when you think back of your catalog
what's your favorite Mac 10 album that
you've been a part of
man they all like feel different because
I was at different times in my life you
know with them but like um
let me see uh
based on a true story one of my one of
my favorite records Yeah Bang a ball is
one of my favorite records they have
also be because I went about it
different I had never made a record like
that I may bang a ball in two weeks two
weeks
two weeks from start to finish literally
wow literally Hayden your eyes was
produced by Dre right yeah Dr Dre did
that yeah so you just got a Dre beat
like in the two-week process he just
sent a Passover and that was one of them
yeah yeah yeah yeah well I actually went
and said with him he played me some
stuff and I liked that one he said all
right this one you if you wanted you can
get it so you know I'm saying and then I
flew I did it then I flew back to
Houston to finish my album because I was
working with Manny fresh you know what
I'm saying so fresh work like that like
do the damn thing was a freestyle I
didn't even write that because he
wouldn't let me write it he was like
just go in there
you listen to the rhyme pattern and
everything he was like just go in there
and just you you a pro just go in there
and just rhyme I kind of to make sure I
do the damn thing I left my nuts hey
yeah yeah it was a straight freestyle he
said I don't want it if you write it
like just go in there and just whatever
you say just just make the next word
rhyme if you can you know what I'm
saying he said I'm telling you it's
gonna come out hard like that just do it
like that so you know Manny fresh one of
the best ever so I listened to him and
uh I did it and do the damn thing it's
one of them records that's that was a
good one me and my small group of
friends in Phoenix had an actual
funny dance we would do when that song
came on that we still like if I play
that song right now my best friend just
was here he would do it uh what was like
first of all talk about like how you
ended up on cash money for that one
project
it was just a situation man I mean you
know priority was uh you know making
some some changes at the time and me and
stunner was already homies and so it
really was just a move it was just a
play you know what I'm saying it was
just a move like like that was already
my homeboy yeah so
when I had to I had a choice either
sign a new deal with priority or sign
this deal
you know I just wanted to try something
different and cash money is like the
hottest label in the world at the moment
yeah and like yeah yeah but but but most
of all them dudes was like solid dudes
with me you know what I'm saying they we
clicked as people they were you know I
would go to New Orleans and it was all
open arms like we was family you know
what I'm saying and vice versa when they
was out here it was like that so this
was something man that we was really
trying I just wanted to like do
something different but I had been
putting I had put a lot of Records out
on priority already yeah you know so you
know when when the opportunity came
and that bag was silly for that one
record I had to do it yeah uh what was
it what was that creative process like
working with a guy like Manny fresh
because you've been in obviously in the
studio with so many other Legends like
Dr Dre yeah what was the difference
between a Manny fresh and some of the
other guys
fresh is like
like I said he the first one to give me
to just go in there and just rap just
right just don't write nothing just
going and just say it you know what I'm
saying and fresh work faster than
anybody I've ever seen he had cooked the
beat up right in front of you like in a
few minutes that's crazy and it is a hit
it's connected for life it's right do
the damn thing is whatever but he cook
it up right there like
quick like right in front of you you
know what I'm saying so
you know fresh one of the best ever man
for real for sure you know like I
remember at one point fresh had missed
platinum in a couple it was some years
had went by and everything was Platinum
you know
that's crazy yeah now I think uh I think
uh Manny fresh when we think when we
always talk about the goats I feel like
we got to keep his name in that
conversation because he kind of formed
the whole sound 100 kicked off Wayne
juvie everything man yeah it's crazy yo
you have always been really good at
expanding like
the West Coast [__] to like other areas
we talk about obviously the cash money
situation you had a great relationship
with Fat Joe back in the day
um what do you like a tribute to that
because I do feel like you kind of like
a lot of La guys were just kind of like
working with other La guys but you did a
really good job of like breaking out of
that mold and just working with
everybody from all over the place I'm a
player
you know players is internationally
known nationally recognized and locally
accepted you feel me I'm a player man if
you trying to get to it you you got to
step outside your neighborhood yeah you
feel me so so I [__] with who [__] with
me you know regardless of where they
from uh or any of that if you [__] with
me I'll [__] with you you know so so I
always had that kind of mentality you
know so I was always trying to expand
and I you know it's good to have allies
everywhere man you know what I'm saying
I'm I'm thinking like I've always
thought big yeah was there for anybody
you tried to sign to who banging that
was like that ended up going on to being
like really big that like maybe it
almost happened or didn't you know
almost got to the finish line but maybe
for whatever reason it didn't work out
smooth Snoop yeah was this after yeah he
was already it was when when death row
was like you know when he was before he
went to no limit so before he went to No
Limit you guys had those combos
paperwork was done wow yeah that's crazy
so
death Rose obviously a rap snoop's a
free agent
and you approach him to come on who
banging and it almost happens I mean if
he a free agent and I'm in the game you
know what kind of [__] would I
be not to shoot for the biggest free
agent out there that's real [__] you
know Jerry Jones gonna shoot for the
coldest [__] out there if he if
he can get his hands on him yeah you
feel me so how close it was really close
to happening what did the paperwork
literally was done it's just you know
some things you know went on but like it
was it was done it had been crazy yeah
yeah Snoop on who banging records yeah
who's not I'd have been crazy too just
for like the perceived politics of that
because like snoop's a big grip you know
we know who you are yeah that'd have
been crazy yeah especially in the 90s
boy listen man I feel like he would have
probably put out some better music too
because I didn't like the first I didn't
like the game is to be sold not to be
sold I didn't like that album I did like
No Limit top dog but yeah shout out to
Snoop that have been crazy
um are you going to be putting out a
body of work obviously the singles out
or if you following this up with the
actual body of work yeah yeah I'm gonna
do I'm gonna put the album up is it done
it's almost done the red print the red
print yeah that's fire yeah it's almost
done
features
um I got some secret features you know
what I'm saying I gotta I can't really
speak on it right now you know what I'm
saying because uh you know I'm still in
the process of doing it but like it's a
hot album like the records is the [__]
is is is one of them good ones I mean 14
years this is a long time man people
want to hear from you yeah yeah I
understand yo do you still go back and
listen to uh any like of your old
catalog like on a regular basis I always
wondered that as an artist like if you
got Classics you like go back and bump
your own [__]
not really every now and then every now
and then I'll run across some and I have
to rewind like [__] was hard right there
you know and I turned up but like
usually I really don't don't listen to
my music really I I heard it so many
times making it until I'm you know I
really don't listen to my music I'm
wondering when okay you obviously are
part in my opinion of the best super
group in rap history West Side
connection yeah
I think bow down is
top five rap album in West Coast history
it's up there man for sure gangster
killing a dope dealers [__] you know
right one of my favorite songs ever
right do you give Mount Westmore a
listen when they drop their super album
like do you check it out as a fan like
just to see like oh you know we kind of
did our super group like let me see what
these guys are doing uh not really yeah
not really I mean uh
I've heard bits and pieces of it you
know what I'm saying but
not not really yeah West Side connection
was a movement a movement yeah it was a
little different a movement yeah and
it's crazy too because like if you think
about like from like bow down to
terrorist threats how many years was
that was that like nine or ten years
difference seven years of fight
something like something like that yeah
yeah something like yeah yeah and it
felt like y'all kind of like picked up
right where y'all left off with those
like right
bow down would you put that up there
with any one of your solo albums in
terms of just bodies of work oh yeah oh
yeah that's a complete body of work yeah
and it was sincere what were like those
Studio sessions like when you guys do
like gangstas Make the World Go Round
like tell me about that record like that
studio session uh
you know it was like uh any other West
Side connect studio session I mean it
was always friendly competition yeah you
know your verse had to be high
you know period just everything it was
friendly competition It was friendly
competition for sure you know but your
your verse your verse had to be hot you
know and if your [__] wasn't hot
somebody might say oh man [__] you might
want to run that back you might want to
go back and write that [__] over or
something did you have to say that to
cube ever I mean you know every every
everybody
if if you've been honest with somebody
and you don't did
as many records as we have together
everybody respect everybody's opinion
yeah you know what I'm saying it could
be a little homie in the room that that
might say to me
you sure you want to say it like you
know what I'm saying and and and if and
if you open-minded dude and you know
everybody got your best interest
you at least gonna gonna hear what he
got to say you know what I'm saying you
you might not always go back and change
it but you you if you're trying to make
Classics you at least got an open mind
you know you least
open to listen do you look at today's
because like today's like hip-hop or
just world climate is very different
than when you were really like Peak Mac
10 era in terms of social media
everyone's got a camera phone and you
obviously were a part of like a hip-hop
power couple when you and T-Boz were
together like I can only imagine if that
would have been happening in today's era
the blogs and the Hollywood unlocks and
you know all that like are you are you
thankful that like you kind of got to
come up in the era you did because
nowadays it feels like it's got to be
tough to be famous because everything's
scrutinized man it is it is you know it
but I'm still a little old school in in
a way that I I ain't gonna participate
all the way right like like everybody
too yeah I ain't gonna do that [__] like
you ain't gonna post everywhere I'm at
right taking pictures of my plate and
[__] when they bring it at the
restaurant man what yeah like what part
of the game was that homie right you
know what I'm saying like like I didn't
really come from that right right right
right I came from when you had money and
when you got up you you tucked off you
didn't you didn't want to just be eating
steaks and dangling show people where
you are yeah yeah you didn't want to be
you know dangling steaks at hyenas right
you feel me you kind of like yeah I mean
it's people have lost their lives
because they show where they are or they
it's it's unfortunate listen do you want
to win some money gotta stop the
interview but listen there's so many
opportunities to gamble to bet on your
favorite sports to make Sports more
interesting NFL season is over but it's
all good because the opportunities to
win are just getting started yeah look
there's so many things you can do we're
talking about NCAA NBA NHL UFC boxing
there's Blackjack tournaments so much
money to get in on and check this out
y'all if you sign up right now using the
promo code bootleg do it right now you
can get a welcome bonus up to a thousand
dollars plus you're gonna get a free
hundred and fifty thousand dollar March
Madness bracket contest entry that's
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
right now get a bonus up to a thousand
dollars you're gonna put in 200 bucks
that could give you 200 you put in a
thousand they'll give you another
thousand right look right now go to
mybookie.ag sign up use that promo code
March Madness is upon us so much great
Sports just NBA season playoffs are on
the way man you could like literally put
together some crazy props like uh I
don't know over under on a player that
you like scoring you could do a future
on the MVP do you think jokic is going
to win it you think Joel embiid's Gonna
Win It Whatever It Is get in on the
action right now mybookie.ag with that
promo code bootleg when you sign up get
that free deposit bonus all right bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
also shout out to our family at hardean
Harding Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with
Jardine you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot him
a follow on Instagram while you're at it
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
so much fly gear so much fly weed what
are we talking about baby shout out to
hard Dean man that's the family man go
if you're in Vegas pull up on them man
Jardine Las Vegas what is your take on
like kind of LA right now man because
obviously we got out of a pandemic a lot
of people running up the EDD you know
people have uh
the robberies we always see it online
people getting robbed out here all the
time people losing their lives out here
artists getting killed out here like do
you I mean it's not like it wasn't
always lit out here you know what I'm
saying but I feel like now it seems like
it's just more publicized how do you
feel about just kind of the state of the
city right now I think it's just more
publicized because there's a lot more
ways that you could find everything out
you know it's been dangerous you know
it's been dangerous I look at I've been
looking at it like it was dangerous yeah
but you know now like you said you got
camera phones you got the internet you
got everything so you know it's just you
know but but but but I think you know
what's going on like been going on it's
just now you know yeah you know that is
true hey as a guy from Inglewood
who to me was the first guy I ever heard
really rep Englewood
Tupac saying Inglewood was always up to
no good was that how big was that for
Inglewood I mean in California Love I
mean it's cool that was that was cool
him Madre whoever said it like like that
was that was that was uh that was love
you know we we you know saying we like
to be recognized amongst the best yeah
yeah for sure shout out to Pac-Man do
you feel like
um for you
when you put an album out in 2023 right
you're working on an album are you
paying attention to what's hot right now
are you just doing Mac 10. I'm doing Mac
10 which is smart because this [__] is
fun to me yeah you feel me uh if it
ain't fun I don't even want to do it
like this this is literally Kevin I'm
really just having fun and I'm doing Mac
10. like when you listen to King of
Chevys that don't sound like I listen to
whoever out now and say okay this what
they doing now that's what I'm gonna do
[__] all that I'm a real one I mean I do
me I think that's smart too because most
artists they get away from like yo this
reason why people love you yeah if you
accepted me like this
I would I would be like a piece of [__]
to give you something different right
why you you didn't that ain't what you
ordered yeah that's crazy yeah so for
you do you listen to the new [__] like
are you listening like little baby are
you listening yeah yeah he's hard he's
hard as [__] yeah [__] could rap for
sure yeah he cold he cold I listen to
the new [__] but I'm still me yep
I can't do number be me bro I'm good at
being me yeah you feel me and so you
gonna get the best of me if I'm if I'm
me I don't care what nobody else is
doing I've been a trendsetter in a in a
a leader my whole life can you feel me
so so so you know I really don't give a
[__] what other people doing I kind of
just do me and just respect everybody
and what they doing that's fair any of
the young La guys that you're you're a
fan of that you're checking all of the
little youngsters now they like like
like I liked them little dudes you know
I like YG I like mustard you know my
little son district is cold as [__]
um
um um uh [__] Ty Dollar like like all
all I mean everybody really all the
little dudes is doing it right now and
it's daytime like I'm proud of them
dudes because because I know how that is
you know what I'm saying that's a good
situation yo when you were making like
independent movies in the 90s
for people who don't know we started off
talking about blood thicker than water
that was a movie with you and Fat Joe um
[Music]
what was like the budget for a a who
banging film back then
I mean I was just doing them them films
like that for you know like I was
shooting doing a record you know so I
probably put a million aside or
something you know what I'm saying wow
that's a good budget for him yeah yeah
yeah yeah but like I'm gonna do the
movie and a soundtrack to it at the same
time there was the soundtrack yeah so it
was the one-two punch the one two
hunting the double up the double up man
yeah yeah would you still like like ever
like do the label thing and try to sign
artists or are you kind of like I mean
obviously once you kind of you're in
your bag as a promoter now you know what
I mean I don't know if it's kind of
worth a headache
that poor idea you feel me but but but
like
I'm always I'm such a music guy though
in a in a good sport right that if I
could help somebody out that that you
know if it's something I could do I I
I'll do it yeah but you know what I'm
saying if I could help somebody or give
them a shot to win you know [__] I I
will but it got to be like that though
you know what I'm saying it got to be
something that you know
you know we feel like we could win which
you know what I'm saying
yo back in the day there was West Side
slaughterhouse
which correct me if I'm wrong
was a bit of a response to Commons I
Used To Love Her am I right about that
yeah it was West Side slaughterhouse and
West Side connection period was just
it was just you know uh uh uh
we was reacting to that common record
yeah common and whoever else you know so
common that's by the way it's one of my
favorite songs ever common I Used To
Love Her such a beautiful record if you
actually like you know but at the time
he pretty much said it
that the girl went to the West Coast and
you know he said unfavorable things
right so Wes are you saying that that
record inspired the group to come
together I ain't gonna say that okay I
just said when it came to West Side
connection we was reacting it wasn't
just common whoever had a problem right
whoever was out of line whoever said
something that we could have took is a
diss or a disrespect we was it wasn't no
running from nothing or hiding from
nothing it was we was responding yeah
West Side slaughterhouse [__] Classic
record but
um did you ever like cross paths with
common ever in the like at any point in
time like you didn't heard them stories
you something else you're a pro at this
[__] though you didn't heard them
stories though well for people who don't
know the stories let's retell them yeah
you know what it is you know what I'm
saying yeah but you know it's all good
man you know shout out to common man
what's up with you homie you know now
he's on TV you know he's on movies shout
out to coming man yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know but we was young man
inactive man you know how that goes yeah
you know what I'm saying so yeah yeah
you know yeah you've had your like I
mean because you and Cypress Hill had a
thing right
yeah of course yeah of course people
know about that was that something that
ever got resolved like you know because
I [__] would be real because yeah you
guys are both ogs
we laugh about it yeah our [__] would be
real what was like the original like or
origin of y'all's issues for people who
need it I didn't have no problem with
them I didn't have no issues with him
Cube had an issue with them okay but I'm
gonna come [__] like if I'm with
you I'm with you you know what I'm
saying so Cube had the issue and so I
just like jumped in it when it came to
Cypress Hill you know what I'm saying
but uh you know I didn't have no issues
winning
yeah so now nowadays fast forward you
guys are solid laugh about that we laugh
about it for real yeah have you have you
uh you might you might already be
involved and I might not know but are
you you know would you get involved in
the Cannabis industry it seems like a
lot of if you're in L.A it's kind of you
know a natural thing to try to get
involved with you know that red gas was
the best weed on the street you know
what I'm saying like like hell yeah yeah
yeah yeah red gas was a line I got you
know but um
yeah yeah I mean
you you know but even the Cannabis
industry ain't what it was for sure
ain't what it was everyone thinks you
just print money that's not how it goes
no it ain't what it was a few years ago
but yeah I got a good product though is
it still out in like dispensaries and
[__] yeah can you get it at Dr
Greenthumb because that would be kind of
uh ironic it's been there it's been
there yeah that's what's up uh what's
your relationship I mean we always hear
that you and Cube don't have much of a
relationship but
is there any sort of like World in which
you guys get together maybe do another
West Side connection have a conversation
like I said earlier I [__] with who [__]
with me hmm you dig that's where I'm at
with it if you [__] with me I'll [__]
with you but if it's [__] me it's [__]
you like I don't I [__] who [__] with me
kill you know what I'm saying and um I
ain't seen him or talked to him in damn
near 20 years so there it is that's so
crazy what about Dub C
man it's just
man y'all got Classics together bruh I
totally understand Classics I totally
get it but you know that's I'm just the
kind of guy that you know I rock with
who rock with me I respect that man yeah
I I think most people should live by
that by that law yeah for sure yeah
there's a right size of bag though
someone comes in with the right bag you
know to do to do Bow Down 2.0 I mean I'm
a businessman yeah
you get the bag you said you get to get
to the bag I'm a businessman yeah and
and it ain't never been me
you know with the hole up it ain't never
been my personality or or who I am with
the hold up of us
doing something it ain't never been me
as the whole up you feel me but
oh
man I [__] with who [__] with me yeah it
is what it is okay respect man yeah for
you are you doing this new album
straight Indie yeah it's bankrolling
everything yeah everything what
producers are you working with
I mean I'm working with quite a few
producers you know what I'm saying some
guys from the East I got a
Trey and some of them guys that did like
you know some of my [__] on my on my
older projects you know what I'm saying
um mustard I did you know you record
with mustard yeah
is that gonna be a single
uh
probably like you get a mustard beat I
mean I mean yeah you know I'm still
putting it together you know what I'm
saying I'm still putting the whole album
together I like to finish like
everything you know and then and then I
always been the kind of guy that
finished everything and and then pick my
singles except for like king of Chevys I
was just like you know it was on the
podcast first and everything you know it
was just one of them records we was just
having fun you know but you the red
printer is a is a good solid project hey
we got to stop the interview to tell you
about our good Folks at Blue chew baby
that's right A lot of people keep asking
me does Bluetooth work [__] yeah it does
and if you don't believe me they'll give
you a whole month for free right now if
you go to bluetooth.com and use that
promo code bootleg that's bootry.com
promo code bootleg you get a month of
blue chew for free delivered to your
[__] house all you do is pay five
dollars in shipping what is blue tree
you ask well let me tell you it has the
same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable tablet but it is
discreetly delivered right to your
doorstep no awkward doctor's visits
imagine going and telling uh an old guy
about your dick
you would prefer not to do that I know
I'd prefer not to do that you know but
you could do it all online bluetooth.com
you don't have to go to the doctor's
appointment in person no more no they're
going to send it straight to your door
all right your wife won't even know it
came your wife won't know
that you came and it came all right so
what you do is
you uh you go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg and you get a month
of uh the whole thing for free that's
right a month supply of Bluetooth for
free straight to your door they also
just dropped their new mint chewable
which is the same exact active
ingredient as Levitra so many options
for you at Bluetooth to make sure your
dick is right going into the springtime
baby look spring break's coming uh are
you gonna be coming
the real question is
is your partner going to be coming
not with the noodle dick
let's be honest make sure that shit's
hard as [__]
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and get a month's supply for
free and if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it's okay man
it happens to the best of us go to
Bluetooth and put a Band-Aid on that
thing bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
also
while we're talking about our partners
shout out to our family at Odd Socks oh
look at these Odd Socks underwear man
they're they're Half Baked
so much going on at Odd Socks uh so many
dope licenses man shout out to uh they
got Cheetos they got Jaws [__] Oreos
Cheech and Chong Naruto WWE by the way
WrestleMania is coming I can't wait to
see what dope WrestleMania socks they do
this year because last year they knocked
it out the park at Odd Socks look the
most comfortable socks in the world they
got The Odd Socks Basics that you need
on your feet uh all you got to do is go
to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg at checkout
you'll save 20 off your total order
underwear socks
[__] hats whatever you need they got it
at Odd Socks uh they just got the
Coca-Cola deal so you go get some
Coca-Cola drawers Coca-Cola socks so
much always going on in Odd Socks I'm
gonna always say my favorites are the
WWE in the Breaking Bad Ones
um so go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you will
save 20 off at checkout shout out to
them most comfortable socks in the world
crazy comfortable underwear my goodness
if you ain't got Odd Socks on your feet
and ass what are you doing out in these
streets all right go to
hotsocksofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off let's get back to the
interview when you guys drop
well bow down was 96 right am I tripping
or was that 96 you can tell me more than
what bow down what was about 96 or 97
probably like 96 or 96 probably a 97
probably book yeah do you feel like when
you look back at those days that like um
the media like the source The Vibes of
the worlds were kind of like creating
this East Coast West Coast narrative
that necessarily was not as big as it
really was
um
I think we I mean to a certain to a
certain extent but but at the same time
it was going on it was actually going it
was going on you know what I'm saying
but yeah like of course
you know beefs and [__] like that you
know it makes for better press you know
don't ain't nobody gonna say that you
know everything is cool that ain't that
ain't a good story right it's only a
story of everybody like Feud and [__]
you know what I'm saying but yeah it
definitely was a situation going on and
yeah all media Outlets do that to a
certain extent yeah but it but there it
you know we did feel some kind of way at
the time yeah it felt like it was like
you know there was like certain artists
kind of taking like Subs at each other
back then and then they'd be like but
then you'd see like you know Method Man
pop up with Tupac you know what I'm
saying or you I mean even a little after
that you were obviously real tight with
Fat Joe Fat Joe yeah yeah because
players recognize players Man game
recognized game yeah you feel me like
man it's players everywhere you know and
like I said I ain't I I wouldn't be the
kind of guy to have this a problem
with an entire I got a problem with who
got a problem with me just like you [__]
with who [__] with you period mm-hmm
you know what I'm saying and and and you
know that's it I got some real solid
dudes that that I've met over the years
from New York and from the East Coast
you know some solid guys yeah do you uh
thinking thinking back to 2001 right you
end up signing with cash money putting
out Banger ball
that's around like right before we get
like Peak Lil Wayne Like Superstar Wayne
I feel like was like oh 405 when he
dropped the first card is when that kind
of started but like were you around
Wayne back then yeah he was a kid like
like 14 15 years old or something when I
was around him yeah I feel like it's
crazy people don't even understand that
like back then like obviously juvie was
juvie but the big timers were the
biggest [__] on cash money out once
juvenile kind of like you know 400
Degrees came out and like I felt like
Soldier red came out or not Soldier rank
soldiers before that a G-Code but uh the
Big Timers were [__] lit big Thomas
was good big time was good but but but
but Junior was a special talent like a
like a a different kind of [__]
like he was I knew he was incredible
like when he was a kid I told stunning
there boy here going to be the business
he gonna be the [__] for real you guys
had sessions together back then and all
that oh yeah yeah it was like a family
all right like I was around like around
around we was all around each other like
for real building you know Wang was
young but I could tell at a young age he
was going to be
probably the best ever
obviously Birdman is like one of the
most prolific CEOs ever we hear like
mixed things though when it comes like
signing with cash money there's people
who have complaints people who say it
went great your experience was great
I don't got nothing to say yeah you know
my experience was was was was was was
player it was a player situation I can't
do nothing but but but but have uh
you know love and respect for for him
and slim you know and all of the guys
that that I've met through them or you
know everybody associated with cash
money has been all Open Arms with me for
you know since the beginning for sure
um who you putting on your Mount
Rushmore
of
La rap not California L.A
your personal amount Rushmore it don't
got to be like who like the the you know
the the publicly politically correct
list just your personal list
that's a hell of a question bro yeah
you know I'm saying that's a really good
question it don't matter what era no not
dude we're talking about rap music from
La the LA area the Los Angeles
metropolitan area your personal well
well I'm putting Easy E at the top of
the list for any [__] thing
they've only come to rap straight up
that's me okay Eric is number one right
and then this [__] for sure this
gangster [__] for sure and so
um I'm gonna start with easy
uh
you know I gotta mention myself
of course
um
dog's been one of the greats yep
you know what I'm saying could have been
on Who band yeah yeah yeah almost yeah I
mean but like it's hard bro because like
you know 40 and short you know both
we're talking about la oh just L.A just
L.A no California just L.A
Eric I mean easy um easy you Snoop one
more
iced tea iced tea not the ice I expected
but a good ice nonetheless because iced
tea kind of is like in my opinion iced
tea was hard at six in the morning and
all that [__] well I also feel like he's
like the pioneer of like yeah it's like
him and Eazy-E low-key like ice tea was
before easy right
in terms of just like I mean I mean
hahaha
I'm not trying to age Paula but I feel
like she would know
no I see definitely I feel like was was
before like I mean iced tea was yeah and
them album covers like the power album
cover yeah well him and his lady with
the shotgun yeah ice was an innovator
bro yeah and he's 23 years straight on
SVU yeah and when you sit out and have a
conversation with him he's like one of
my favorite people to sit down and talk
to yeah ice be popping that [__] like
still still like you're gonna leave with
some Jewels [__] with ice you know
you'll say some players gentlemen ain't
on him man he's gonna say some fly [__]
for sure uh what is your Chevy
collection like these days
I mean you know the Chevy collection 57
um
uh
64 uh
52 um
and and I got a two-door Brom a Cadillac
you know what I'm saying have you like
can you tell me the most well first of
all I'm sure you've you've bought and
fixed up car sold cars gone in and out
of a lot of vehicles
what was the most expensive Chevy you
flipped
um
[__] that off that that I that I that I
flip like so that you sold to someone
else
because I mean I'm sure you've gone
through a ton of Impalas over the years
oh yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah uh
what about 200 200 000 200 Jesus but now
but like now that ain't [__] now because
that's like now now now
the [__] I got now if I was selling I
couldn't sell nothing for less than 300.
wow you know what I'm saying yeah I
don't feel like I see like 64 Impalas
anymore I remember like
it was such a big part of the culture
when I was a kid man like the city but
you know yeah but like the Chevys build
my [__] so like they [__] they they they
set the bar at a different standard you
know what I'm saying is like it's all
the way like showroom floor like like
like like the semi line you feel me like
this is that your car yeah all of my
[__] is like clean like that is that
like do you take like pride and
rebuilding the car like that and getting
it back to kind of how it came because
that's got to be expensive it's got to
be hard it's expensive and and time
consuming for sure you know what I'm
saying but
that brings me way more satisfaction
than the new [__] you know what I'm
saying and I got everything I had
everything got everything like all the
new [__] but like
that old [__] is special how do you like
a Tesla though because I I said Model S
yeah how do you feel about the Tesla
it's the fastest car in the world I know
it's the fact but like you [__] with it
like I mean I'm a Chevy guy but I'm just
a car guy right right I'm a car guy like
you could have one of them if you got
some other [__] right you know what I'm
saying but like but like I I
that model S plaid is a it's a fun car
to drive like I heard that shit's like 0
to 60 and like I don't need 1.9 seconds
insane yeah yeah like well 1200
horsepower so anything somebody pull up
on yeah it ain't never gonna be able to
[__] with you although I ain't even
trying to go that fast like that I'm I'm
I'm just trying to just you know what
I'm saying I miss a car guy right like
all the new [__] that come out like I'm
I'm a car dude so you know I'm gonna
have something they gotta start giving
cops these Teslas because if I'm in the
[__] Tesla I'm smoking the cop yeah
I'm out of there yeah it's like you
can't keep up with me I got 1200 horses
here sir yeah yeah
it's like it's like um any car though
you gotta had a right one though you
know the right one because if you got
the wrong [__] you you look like a
square right right you gotta have like
the right car so what's the right Tesla
to have a Model S plaid it's got to be a
plaid 250. 200 yeah at least two yeah
yeah yeah but a plaid if it a plaid is
the is is is is the that's it uh as a
businessman besides throwing shows and
building this other Empire outside of
Music uh congrats on that too
um what else are you doing you're doing
real estate are you getting involved in
any of their yeah I've been doing real
estate since the 90s since the mid 90s
like since I first got in the in the in
the game really I've been [__] with
real estate tough since then
I mean consistently
how many houses in Inglewood did you
hold on to because right now they got to
be booming I didn't hold on to no house
in Inglewood no no I don't know you wish
you would have not really not really I
mean I got relatives over there yeah
yeah but like man I've I've bought [__]
in in areas that that like you know ball
[__] and flipping in areas where the
where the value like super low nowhere
to Value like quadrupled like what areas
I mean anywhere in in what real estate
is all about location location location
straight up you feel me so so so me I
was always trying to buy houses I didn't
did a couple in the neighborhood but
like you know you know some of that will
and Hill [__] oh the valley is crazy you
know like the [__] costs four or five
times more than what you paid for you
feel me so so so you know it's location
location with real estate for you being
an OG somebody who's kind of been
through so much in this city man been
through so much in the rap game
you know hits uh issues drama [__]
peaks of success uh what would be your
advice to
um artists who come out here to LA
because you you know there's like we
talked about earlier people are
definitely
getting targeted out here now you know I
always tell people if you can come out
here and move around like a [__]
they're gonna treat you like a [__]
right like if you're gonna come out here
and wear 200 000 in jewelry and just
think [__] sweet that's what do you want
people to do if they're hungry you know
what I'm saying but how would you advise
people to move in Cali based on the OG
perspective
this is you know
you know [__] you got to know where you
at you know what I'm saying move
accordingly you know
move according to to
where you at I mean be smart be smart
for sure you know what I'm saying and
respect the situation
because any City that I go to I respect
the situation that's that's somebody
else town it's somebody else City you
feel me so I'm gonna come in you know
and and you know conduct myself like a
player and respect the situation gotta
be respectful yeah I mean you know what
I'm saying you do you got to respect the
situation and be smart about what you're
doing I mean some [__] ain't gonna fly
straight up straight up it just ain't
gonna fly that's real [__] you know as a
promoter who's been the artist you've
booked the most
I don't know bro like um that's a hard
question give me like the top two or
three that come to mind that guys I did
a lot of Lil Wayne shows lots of Wayne
shows I did a lot of Wayne shows good
business to be I did a lot of Snoop
shows good business to be in this I
heard Stoops price is shot up recently
yeah once you're getting that crypto
money you can ask for a lot more yeah
yeah on all the r b guys I've I've done
them like you know over and over and
over Keith Sweat all them guys a million
times yeah you know what I'm saying hey
how important has the Latin uh fan base
been to you man because I feel like
you're heavily uh embraced by you know
the brown Community hey man I love a
brown Community been like my number one
base my number one fan base you feel me
so like
mag 10 is down with the brown like a
[__] like straight up yeah like
like I I keep them in mind when I'm
doing music
because I look at I look at the uh
Hispanics is like
my core fans like my real fans you know
what I'm saying and before I put a
record out I think to myself like well
my fans like this you know what I'm
saying right and if and if uh
you know if the if if if if if if the
answer is no then it probably won't make
the cut that's what's up man well listen
you're a [__] Legend
appreciate it appreciate you pulling up
new song King of Chevys is out yeah uh
the red print coming soon yes sir how
soon before the end of the year before
summer yeah Summertime Summertime
probably summertime yeah uh you're
already getting music videos together
doing that doing that now doing all of
that finna dudes gonna shoot a couple of
more videos coming up here in the next
few weeks uh my last question if you
were to put together your own super
group
right now
who was who's in the Mac 10 super group
in 2023 Who you calling
it don't got to be anybody from anywhere
in particular it could be it could be
[__] 2023 yeah
[__] I'm a one-man band I'm calling Ray
solo calling me you me and 23. just you
like that okay
well there it is man
well I appreciate you pulling up Mack 10
man they went up the new things so my
guy boom right on fire